elle concerne une émission dont tout le
monde a parlé jeudi soir qui s'appelle
balances ton par we had échoué ça
méritait pas si on vous a classé
neuvième succès mérité 9e fort et
c'était bordeaux les bonnes questions de
vous sur votre équipe
nissan va vous posez vous les bonnes
questions sur votre avenir nombreuses
séquences qui ont attiré mon attention
dans balance tant pas je voudrais dire
juste merci à vous parce que la chaîne
était encore première chaîne nationale
sur les 485 énorme carton première
chaîne tnt et troisième chaîne sous lbo
balance et merci donc merci a vainement
malgré une concurrence diouf
ouais merci endurance et donc il y avait
notamment parmi vos invités juan branco
qui est un avocat sympathisants d'ee et
gilet jaune
oui et alors le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'il a un peu fait parler de lui
ce soir là face à vous et notamment
d'abord il a d'abord été assez virulent
avec les chroniqueurs on regarde d'abord
si vous voulez bien son face à face avec
les chroniqueurs donc vous avez fait une
petite distance a fait une compil un
petit peu partie gagné combien par mois
pour être sur ce plateau
moi je suis l'argent que vous savez
combien d'argent vous savez que les
inconditionnels troc site du moulin
social broutteux les semaines on
n'essaie pas les enveloppes l'allemagne
qui monsieur naulleau pour juger de son
action
moi je suis comme ça moi je suis si
monopoly comme je vous attend à la porte
berne à la portée de son couplet sarkozy
bernard laporte et qui est en train de
se garer ici derrière après avoir été
nice de sarko j'adore et je vous dis un
truc je vous jure que c'est vrai que
juan branco et mois après on a fini
l'émission on s'est parlé on était très
copains alors mesdames et je vous jure
que c'est vrai qu'on a fait on s'est
même envoyé d'un petit sms ce week-end
mais ont duré trois bêtises ces
salopards de btp est juste un frère
c'est ce que j'aime moi voilà yadav ya
ensuite eu une petite halte en face à
une telle question en tout cas vous avez
voulu mettre les choses au point les
points sur les i en montrant qu'il était
plus politisés qu'est-ce qui me voulait
montrer sur eux mêmes et ne savent pas
pourquoi ils manifestent face à ce
mépris comment est ce que vous voulez
que ces gens vous ne le sont pas si je
vous dirai juste de la prostitution
si non c'est ici non je suis pas dit la
vérité j'ai été de la france assure
isabelle c'est quand même écouter
bernard et essayez de vous parler de ça
vaut quatre journées d'action nous en
parler vous parlez vous êtes en campagne
beau si je ne veux pas la prétention sur
vous payez arrêté d'extension veut pas
de gens campent à 10 6 me
ce qui est formidable c'est que
l'échangé continuer hélas il ya eu
justement une mise au point parce que il
vous a attaqué sur ce qu'ils croyaient
de votre salaire et là vous
et là vous avez voulu mettre les choses
au point avec lui vous parlez
d'altercations voilà regarde d'un peu de
chose par donc un petit peu ouais mais
ça vous mais pour les gens qui sont au
chômage on y va et je me base d'une
forêt de jambes déjà les jeunes qui sont
débattues et des niçois ont fait quoi
oui je me défendrai chez les jeunes
gratuitement à tous les jours les fans
on gagne pas de 150 millions d'euros en
cinq ans pour faire ce que tu gagnes pas
de voir à quoi tu dis des conneries qui
sortent et ceux qui voudraient pas du
tout mais tu dis des bêtises du montant
demandé de vous aider à vous ai
transmises pas ce que vous dites qui en
promet pas là tout va ce que tu en
campagne ici pourquoi pas de moi mais
qu'elle voulait être élu qui est bien
payé comme ça vous rend fou dit pas de
diriger demain je veux nous rend fous je
suis engagé ce qui me rend fou c'est ta
connerie
est-ce que son show ce qu'on peut mettre
à votre crédit c'est que moi c'est après
afin que je vois un animateur dira de
ses invités du méchoui c'est sa balance
compost et sans dire que vous que vous
ne jouez pas de rôle et que vous êtes le
relais à l'antenne et hors antenne et là
j'ai revu mon copain tu parlais à
quelqu'un en face de lui avec pau pour
qu'il y ait un punch et rien contre lui
parce qu'il est très sain il est très
intelligent du garçon est d'ailleurs
justement comme toujours avec vous ça se
finit bien présent mais celle de jean
chrétien rien apaisé un grenouille c'est
juste que je lui reprochais je vous dis
la vérité c'est qu'il avait été candidat
france insoumise et qui voulait pas le
dire moi j'ai rien contre la france
insoumise parce que je m'entends très
bien avec eux franchement et voilà que
lexie corbières je m'entends sur l'île
de ré je m'entends très bien avec alexis
corbière
j'aime beaucoup jean luc mélenchon et
qui je m'entends très bien également
voilà mais je ne veux pas je ne voulais
pas de mec politisé sur le plateau les
gilet jaune ne sont pas politisés
ils sont là pour faire passer des idées
et voilà cinq mois maintenant je vous le
dis je me suis un peu renseigné sur lui
ce week end aussi et c'est vrai que il
fait des choses pour les jaunes donc je
trouve ça très bien de sa part et je
vous dit on à échanger tous les deux et
d'ailleurs ce céline c'est justement la
banque de culte du caire qui vous tient
vraiment à coeur je peux après ça s'est
bien terminé entre je te dis j'ai aucun
gilet jaune qui me reproche mais réussit
bien au contraire c'est en train de
créer une association là et je te
demande pas d'argent je mange juste
d'emménager commandes de l'argent non
mais ça demande de l'argent aux plus
aisés parce que je sais qu'à des
inégalités coin est plus aisé comme moi
voilà de données chaque année encore
encore rien les les impôts mais il faut
donner encore parce qu'il ya des mecs
qui sont vraiment dans la merde et que
là quand on est dans des situations
comme ça c'est à nous aussi de bouger je
te le dis les plus aisés et de dire ben
moi chaque année eh ben je vais donner
encore un peu plus parce que je peux pas
je peux pas laisser les gens dans
l'annuaire
c'est chaque mois il ya 400 personnes
qui travaillent pour nous sommes très
heureux de les faire travailler ici mais
voilà on s'est un peu embrouillé avec
trois morts aujourd'hui dans une société
c'est difficile de réussir
en tout cas c'est vrai que valence ou
pas c'est vous qui parlez et je vais
vous parler de l'émission de jeudi
vous allez voir c'est ça va être encore
c'est un grand moment de télé parce que
lui il est extrêmement pénible
ils avouent ils débrouillait besoin il a
un ego démesuré mais il est bon et c'est
vrai que quand on regarde son cv il a
fait beaucoup de choses devraient alors
certains lieux lui reproche de brasser
de l'air car qui fait des choses il
arrête mais il a fait plein de choses
après je vais vous dire un truc aussi on
m'a reproché de ne pas avoir pris et je
le dis ce soir dans tpp de n'avoir pas
sorti l'argument parce que voilà rendre
moins coûteux faut savoir il est d'une
famille très très riches oui moi je suis
rentré là c'est donc voilà bien sûr il
est d'une famille très riche qui peuvent
pas se battre pour les gilet jaune
voilà et c'est trés son argument et
c'est pour ça que son discours est
dangereux et moi je trouve que c'est un
discours qui est populiste est
profondément populiste et ils nous
posent toujours les riches et les
pauvres comme si les riches n'avaient
pas le droit et ne pouvait pas se
mobiliser pour les pauvres où les gens
qui n'avaient pas de problème
spécialement ne pouvait pas faire des
choses pour les pauvres
et ce discours là c'est très dangereux
sert il on peut pas laisser dire des
choses comme ça franchement ça ok ça
sert français discours de ne pas l'aimer
mais il al assi dextérité en livre nikos
ce qu'il dit c'est pour ça que c'est un
grand la phase assez calme et c'est vrai
que la face à ces crimes et c'était
assez cordiale affamés dans l'extrait
qu'on ait vu juste avant juste après cet
échange que vous cédiez est ce que vous
êtes dit d'intérieur mangeant ça va trop
loin c'est en train de m'échapper sas le
débat s'emporte autre os et avec la
bague ont tous passé par mois passera
devant la fois je me suis dit ça va loin
quand je suis trois ans à l'époque a
nommé ballon ce qu on fasse une émission
en direct 2d là c'était je sais que ça
peut aller très loin et au contraire
c'est ce que je veux dans l'émission et
on fera toujours l'émission sans filet
et sans masque
voilà d'après s'est retourné je me suis
dit ça va ou jimmy non moi je sais un
militant politique qui cherchait son
heure de gloire
d'accord il fait pas avancer les choses
a tant cherché le buzz chercher la
lumière il l'a eu
et vous avez gardez votre sang froid je
ne pense pas que je leur ai eu parce que
les gens oublient ce que vous faites en
dehors du plateau lorsque les lumières
sont éteintes
vous venez parler avec les gens vous
n'avez pas besoin de ça vous pourriez
rentrez chez vous tranquillement mais
vous cherchez à aider donc que les deux
angels on fasse un dixième ce que vous
faites et puis ensuite ils viendront sur
les plateaux télé faire les beaux moi je
pense que c'est dangereux d'opposer les
riches et les pauvres moi je suis
médecin je gagne bien ma vie mais c'est
pas pour autant que je ne comprends pas
les gelées je ne sais pas pourtant qu'il
faut leur tourner le dos et de se dire
bon bah c'est bon moi je faire passer
donc les opposer les gens aux autres ça
n'avance rien et je pense qu'ils
cherchaient simplement